[Music]
hi Colonel Brian here we are now three
weeks out just three weeks out from the
new show on TBS very excited we're
getting ready and today I'm answering
question number five this is from Jason
Ross he's from Los Angeles California
here's his question hi cone and oh did
you stay in Los Angeles or did you go
back to New York or are you in a new
city for the new show okay well to
answer your question we are in Los
Angeles where you live Jason I'm shocked
you haven't seen me around I'm pretty
hard to miss I stand out I'm six foot
nine with orange hair anyway we are here
in Los Angeles we are shooting on the
Warner Brothers lot and very excited
about that we've got a satin everything
but just to say that we're here in LA at
the Warner Brothers lot doesn't tell you
where we really are I want to give you a
better clue about where we are better
visual sense this is my office follow me
right out here outside stage 15 you can
see there are some people walking around
hello and right down there parked right
outside my window is our head writers
car he's got a white convertible BMW and
no my head writer is not a 16 year old
girl who just got a prom gift from her
dad my head writer is Mike Sweeney that
is his convertible car I think if you
parking convertible outside my window
you're asking for trouble
and I'm gonna throw some stuff into it
right now let's start with boy help me
out some toilet paper let's just toss it
in there it's really fun to just own
that whoa that bounced out a shall we
there's a coffee mug in the front seat
oh this is my laundry right here let's
just get that out there get rid of that
marshmallows nothing like marshmallows
thrown into a convertible from a great
height sweet so that's where we are
Warner Brothers lot stage 15 Los Angeles
California
convertible filled with crap outside my
office window if you have more questions
go to facebook.com slash Team Coco I'll
talk to you soon
[Music]